coming on the heels of Jill Biden's
breakfast taco remark voters are frankly
sick of the pandering from Democrats and
the media alike according to the hill
Hispanic Democrats in Congress outnumber
Hispanic Republicans four to one but
right now we're seeing a new generation
of Republican candidates all across the
country the national Republican
Congressional committee says it has
recruited a total of 102 Hispanic
candidates this cycle two of them are
here with me tonight joining me now is
Virginia Congressional candidate yazli
Vega and Texas Congressional candidate
Cassie Garcia ladies thanks for joining
me yesterday I want to go to you first
so is this alignment real which I think
it is and if if Hispanics are moving
from Democrat to Republican why
it absolutely is real look this past
November we proudly delivered 54 of the
Hispanic vote to Governor juncken this
is a movement and there's nothing the
liberal Democrat Party can do to stop
this movement while Progressive
activists were pushing uh to cut police
budgets Across the Nation guess who has
felt the skyrocketing crimes in our
community communities of color we felt
the impacts of it we see the failed
leadership coming from the Democrat
Party and we've had enough we are rising
to the occasion and we're going to send
a loud resounding message this November
that the Democrat Party is not entitled
to our vote that they don't represent
our values and that it is time now to
restore our blessed Republic
you know Kathy I I have a podcast with
my wife it's called from the kitchen
table she's she's a Latina I have 12
little uh Latinas Latinos at home
um the comment by Jill Biden in the taco
comment was incredibly offensive we talk
about it on our podcast from the kitchen
table but do you have to talk about
tacos and Hispanics when you can't talk
about abortion inflation Faith you can't
talk about school choice you can't talk
about the issues that really matter to
the community so you talk about tacos is
that is that the deal yeah
you know Sean thank you for having me on
tonight you know Democrats want to
control how we speak we don't talk about
pronouns like all Americans we're
worried about Rising food prices and
crime in our communities the Democrats
are so out of touch they think Hispanics
will vote for them if they talk to us
about tacos and promote open borders but
those are not the values of South Texas
we believe in the American dream God
strong borders and opportunities for our
families I'm proud of my Heritage my
family and the people in our community
came to this great country to work hard
not to be dependent on the government so
every day I meet people who tell me they
voted for democrats for decades but that
is no longer their Abuelo's Democratic
party it's become too radical elitist
and out of touch of our values
yeah and to that point we're going to
talk about this a little bit later
tonight but the attack on the Catholic
Church on all churches people of faith
is very real and Democrats don't seem to
give any pushback any uh condemnation
and you know if you're speaking broadly
the Hispanic Community is a you know the
Community of Faith does that come into
play yesley as well as to why Democrats
are losing the Hispanic vote
it absolutely is because we're seeing a
double standard I know that Cassie Mida
has also felt the impacts of the bias
that we receive not just from the media
but from a Democrat Party that claims to
support women and minorities but the
moment that they realize that you're a
conservative woman they no longer want
to support you and so we received
pushback like never before they're
calling us fake Latinas but listen we're
going to block out the noise because we
know what the task ahead means and it
means that we're going to win we're
going to take back the house look we
continue to Champion life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness while radical
Democrats are more interested in forcing
our sons to be daughters and our
daughters to be Sons we are focused on
the issues and we're going to send a
message this November that our vote is
going to have to be earned
Kathy quickly if you're talking to Kevin
McCarthy if you're talking to the uh
Republican committee what advice do you
give them if they want to win Latinas
they want to win the Hispanic vote what
do they have to do
so talking to working with leadership
right now they're supporting our right
races here in South in South Texas with
Mida with Monica De La Cruz and 15 my
race and yesi Vega over in Virginia you
know the Biden policies are hurting the
families of South Texas right now the
Biden border crisis we talk about baby
formula shortage and the energy crisis
in our district and we are going to see
a red wave come this November the
Democrat Party has left the Hispanic
community and so we're going to see more
Hispanics more Democrat Hispanics vote
Republican come this November we are
going to see a red tsunami take over
like never before we are going to make
history and we're going to flip three
seats in the Rio Grande Valley and
Virginia and with yesterday Vega is also
going to win as well and so we are going
to make history we believe in the
American dream
ladies I gotta tell you what I live with
a Latina don't mess with Latinas because
you will get the fire and brimstone
coming at you good luck in your races
and thanks for joining me tonight I
appreciate it
thank you we're just getting started
thank you
yes yes you are
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else